okay this is Sarah we register nurse RN
calm and today I just want to
demonstrate and show you how to prep for
your IV before you start an IV there's
some things that you have to do you have
to get your supplies ready and you have
to make sure that everything works
properly caps are connected and that
you're ready to go before you actually
stick the patient and get the IV so
today I just want to go to the supplies
and how to prime your ints and show you
how that's done first we have our IV
start pivot these are in most clean
molds you can get that it has everything
that you will need to start your IV and
I'll go over that in a second you will
need an extension to connect to the IV
this right here that I have is a long
extension some facilities just have the
cab or they have this so you can choose
either one you need get your IV that you
plan on using this is a 22 gauge it's
one of the smaller ones but be sure to
ask yourself if this patient might be
getting blood if so they need an 18
gauge or a 20 gauge also get a flush
because you will need a flush to flush
your line and
the IV is pained that it has infiltrated
and that it feels good on the patient so
make sure you always get
saline flush these are normally
prefilled some sillies may not have the
pre-build where you actually have to
draw up your on-site link but they're
going more towards the prefilled
syringes so if that so first let's go
over to your kit this is how I set up
for my IVs there's really no standard
for that it's what you learn over time
and what you get used to so this is what
I do open my kit and in the kit this is
a kit that this type of closure gets may
be different at your facility but this
kit has a tourniquet you'll use that to
put on the patient's arm to get your
vein my normally like to first off look
remain on my patient and so I put that
on them then this is your tape you will
use your tape to secure the IV secure
and your IV is so important because if
you don't take the down your audience
without I've had that happen to me a
couple times and I learned fast to
always take my IV nail so what I
normally do is it comes with this that
you pull back pull back and I peel about
several inches off of tape long enough
just take that all and take this end off
as well and I like to cut it or tear it
in half like that because I take each
piece of tape and tie around the IV
cannula part which I'll show you a
little bit later so in the meanwhile I
just stick this beside of me so after I
get the IV I can take it down really
fast so I'm just going to stick this
then you also have your cleaner you
always clean your side after you find
your vein to prevent infection this
right here this kit comes with betadine
people are allergic to betadine so
always ask if your pit came with
betadine are allergic to betadine
because you wouldn't want to use this
how this would work is you would crack
it and when you crack it all the
betadine bills right here and you clean
the patient's skin off normally new kits
are coming with what's called
chlorhexidine alcohol and it's just a
really
take that cleans and it works the same
way this right here is just a regular
alcohol kind so if your patient was
allergic to betadine don't use that use
okay here is your date and time you'll
be your day at the time what engage of
IV you started and your initials are
name and depending on your hospital
protocol IVs are only only good for five
days and have to be changed out and this
just let it's oncoming nurses know how
my IVs been it if it needs to be changed
and if they couldn't see the gauge of
needle and who started it so it's very
important to put that also included in
the kit is a band-aid I don't use that a
lot unless I miss or I'm removing the IV
and then gauze of course if you get
blood around the fitting on-site you can
clean your blood up or you can if you
miss you can cover the insertion site up
so that is what is in your kit next
right here is the extension like I was
saying before that and some facilities
have the caps but this is an extension
that would screw onto the IV once you
hit the IV right here this is a tip
whenever you are starting your IV and
you prime your line because you need to
prime this with saline which all
in a second there's air in here okay so
you have to get rid of this air and
prime it with the Saline prevent
injecting air in your patient so what I
like to do is I get my saline out this
comes with free build station which
makes your job a lot easier and it this
saline is a little air bubble you will
have to get this air bubble out because
you don't want to inject air into the
patient so what you do is take your
little cap off and use really good
technique if you don't want to
contaminate the needle and you gently
just pull back on the plunger okay and
then just push and then you get your air
out just like that and then I like to
put my pad back on just a little bit
sterile
now what I do because this is still
sterile
I hold this and you screw on its
needleless so you scroll on here and you
just
fish some saline in until it comes out
of the end see how it's coming out at
the end that's nice and primed and I
like to keep the cat off of this this
cat was on the end because this part
right here is going to screw into the
cannula part of the IV and I remember
one time is started an IV and I forgot
to take my pad off because you only have
two hands and one finger is going to be
putting fresh and down the IV line his
blood come out of the IV line so I left
the cap on and I wasn't able to fold and
crush this cat off of the cannula and
end of this and blood came out how to
hurry up so good to just take this cat
ball and keep it clean and sterile by
just putting it back in its package so
it won't go anywhere I just like to do
that so after I start my idea I could
have scrapped my saline and then just
connect to the IV and flush out Drive
bottom and then here's your needle this
is a 22 gauge it's blue I have a video
on IVs the different gauges because
there are different colors there's green
and pink and those are different
this is the 22 and what I do I get ready
to prep the patients stick then remove
the cap and what will happen you will
insert your IV and you'll have to thread
the cannula eyeball up the straw with
the proper tanks anyone into the day and
you will have it in the bay there's your
needle you always hit your button to get
the safety and to trigger so the needle
goes into you belong to the stick but
I'm not going to do I'm just going to
sew to the side and once your ID is in
the vein this little straw right here
was set in the bank and whenever that is
you'll have blood coming out and you'll
want to hold some compression right
there and you'll take your IV thing may
be primed being careful and you'll screw
it right there like so make sure you get
it very tight because if you don't love
leak out the end so you have it
connected this is in your patient and
you're just going to flush some saline
like so see it's starting out right
there and that's just going in there
Bank whenever you do that you're going
to fill around this side make sure it
doesn't bubble up and the patient may
say how will that hurt that stings
that's normally not a good sign
that means that that saline is governing
the surrounding tissues and it's
infiltrated so you'll want to take it
out if the patient says oh that's cool
filling or who it feels like something's
dripping down my arm or I can taste your
smell something that's generally a good
sign because your saline is in the
system in the vein so you have that then
that's in and you'll use your tape that
I showed you earlier to tape down the
site
and I like to put my tape underneath the
wings and then just crisscross it like
so and tape it down onto their skin and
have it nice and secured but it's a
little Tegaderm or whatever you have and
tape it down so that right there is how
to set up your supply a little little
bit into actually starting the IV I have
a video that I'll be making on how to
start an IV so please check that out and
if you have any questions on the
different gauge needles of IVs how to
start how to actually start an IV or
fine veins please check out my other
videos on IVs and thank you so much for
watching and please go to visit our
website register nurse orange on home
for more nursing school tips a nursing
school health and thanks again bye